emmanuel macron wants to win a second
term as france's president and for now
opinion poll suggests that he's likely
to succeed at a packed stadium outside
paris macro held the first rally of his
campaign the centrist leader promised
more jobs tax cuts and to continue with
his pro-eu agenda
we are a european nation and proud to be
one we are no one's vassal we pursue
politics and diplomacy that are
independent we talk to everyone all the
time that's what we do france's role is
not to give in to divisions that
paralysis
macros said that these are challenging
times the past five years have certainly
tested his ability to handle a crisis
his diplomatic efforts over ukraine have
played out well with most french voters
as has his management of the covid
pandemic his government injected
billions of dollars into the economy to
protect businesses and jobs
kovid ukraine he's managed it all well
calmly we can't complain and he will win
we are living in catastrophic times
kovid the war he's a fair president he's
neither left or right but in the middle
and that's exactly what we need right
now macro is leading the presidential
race for now but in recent days his
nearest rival the far-right leader
marine le pen has closed the gap by
focusing on the issue that most voters
say they are concerned by in this
campaign the cost of living
energy is not a luxury or a waste but a
basic necessity so as i proposed as far
back as september are lower tax on fuel
heating oil gas and electricity
le pen's focus on rising prices has
deflected the spotlight from her
anti-immigration anti-islam agenda and
widened her appeal but some analysts say
it's unlikely to be enough for a victory
macron's social and economic track
record is seen as pretty poor by some
french people but he's benefiting from
what we call the rally round the flag
effect where different parts of society
support a leader at a time of grave
international crisis
one week before the first round and
france's election seems likely to be a
rerun of the 2017 race in which a second
round between macro and le pen pit
centrist politics against rising
populism natasha butler al jazeera
non-terror